[Music]
from Peter Jackson the visionary
director of Lord of the Rings comes a
film ten years in the making because he
shunted it off to his storyboard an
effects guy to make the Hobbit well
that's one more thing I can blame on The
Hobbit movies mortal engines welcome to
a post apocalypse earth a world that
still seems pretty okay looking
nevertheless humanity is forced to fight
over limited resources by using tons of
resources on massive mobile cities that
devour smaller mobile cities in a
harrowing game of Hungry Hungry Hippos
except for the humans that live in sky
cities or in mobile home parks or in
just Normal cities which will make you
wonder why parts of humanity have
decided to live on massive bubble cities
that consume smaller mobile cities in a
harrowing game of Hungry Hungry Hippos
the Earth's crust gets shattered into a
thousand pieces is it though when the
world is threatened by an ancient weapon
the only thing standing in its way
are these extremely attractive people
and these extremely attractive people
and also these extremely attractive
people whose names you won't remember
except for Hester because her undead
cyborg dad won't stop shouting it
together they'll take on professional
bad person Hugo Weaving in a special
effects field race wait did I just say
undead cyborg dad
even narrates the intro the age of the
great predator cities there some movie
is ridiculous gear up for a visual feast
of incredible art design and intricate
detailed concepts then choke on an
entire series worth of these things all
crammed into one movie you're just two
skivvy from the lower tiers
if those dim-witted spanner heads
beaches the bins again you'll be back to
cleaning the bogs what the hell is
southies scabs they're the roush on the
end attraction league of Schenck whoa
nothing can stand in the face of this of
the battle hammers of Archangel not the
howitzers of Kansas dad not even the
guns of the antique traction ists as it
rushes past all the cool stuff you'll
actually want to see and explore so that
it can just do Star Wars
[Music]
you guys are missing is the father
revealed no mother never told you you
already knew yep really set myself up
for that one
so put on your fanciest waistcoat and
top that off with your most ridiculous
hat for an ambitious project that made
sure to do every dystopian earth trope
all of the steampunk things and as much
social commentary as possible may very
well be they forgot how to read and
write altogether but for God to tell a
story you can follow with characters you
actually care about so you probably
forgot to see it man and we're never
gonna find out at the Shangri knees and
attraction as and municipal darkness can
coexist or what any of those words even
mean starring in miny danger do you want
to know how I got these scars flower of
London sky captain and a world of
Taekwondo previously on the walking dead
London crawling people falling
people follow
people fall a
and these actual names from the movie
Valentine Bettis that is part have it
man offense the police a Beauregard
penny boy who was my father's name
who call me Nimrod why is everyone in
the post apocalypse so dang pretty where
my pasty subterranean incest
cannon-fodder ad click the boxes to
check out our show's panel to screen
infinity war and the evolution of the
Hulk have you ever danced with the devil
in the pale moonlight I'm a little
teacup you were instant ramen is ready
what would you do for a Klondike bar